[Music]
good evening at welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight how about this is a
mental exercise try to remember back to
the year 2009 was only a decade ago but
it feels like a totally different era in
many ways it was in 2009 most people
didn't have smartphones late night
television was still funny the
Democratic Party was still pretending to
put the interests of American citizens
above those of the rest of the world in
September of 2009 President Obama gave a
speech about health care to a joint
session of Congress you may remember it
one of Obama's most emphatic promises in
that speech and in fact during that
whole season was that foreigners living
in our country illegally would never
receive benefits under his plan he said
that repeatedly but not everyone
believed him watch there are also those
who claim that our reform efforts would
ensure illegal immigrants this too is
false the reforms the reforms I'm
proposing would not apply to those who
are here illegally you'll I yelled
someone in the room that man was
Congressman Joe Wilson of South Carolina
for the crime of being rude to Saint
Obama Wilson was instantly denounced by
his fellow Republicans totally
disrespectful Huff John McCain who
himself had spent decades yelling
obscenities at people in Capitol Hill
Jimmy Carter called Wilson a racist and
yet it turns out that Joe Wilson was
right a decade later the Democratic
Party has abandoned any pretense that
America exists to benefit Americans they
tell us our country is innately evil
that it was conceived in racism for the
purpose of oppression we are a sinful
nation and to redeem ourselves we must
sacrifice for the world's poor among
many many many other things
this means paying the healthcare bills
of foreign nationals who have no right
to be here in the first place watch Joe
Biden explain look I think that anyone
who is in a situation where
they're in need of health care
regardless of whether the doctor unit or
undocumented we have an obligation to
see that they're careful that's why I
think we need more clinics around the
country whether they have documents or
not this isn't a fringe candidate you
just saw it's not Mike Gravel or some
Green Party wacko that's the former Vice
President of the United States he's now
the frontrunner for the Democratic
nomination as it tonight Joe Biden is up
by 25 points over the rest of the field
two years now Biden could easily be
President chances are his running mate
would be senator Camel Harris of
California and over the weekend Harris
made it official she agrees with Joe
Biden on this question illegal aliens
deserve full government health care
watch so you support giving universal
health care Medicare for all to people
who are in this country illegally let me
just be very clear about this I am
opposed to any policy that would deny in
our country any human being from access
to public safety public education or
public health period let me be very
clear about this so you know you're not
taking her out of context we even got
the hand gestures she's telling us that
we have an obligation to pay the medical
bills of every illegal alien in this
country period as she said now how many
people would that be exactly well we
don't know in fact we have no idea
thanks to lobbying from elected
Democrats like Kamel Harris nobody knows
how many illegal aliens live in this
country right now it could be 12 million
it could be 40 million but one thing is
for sure once the rest of the world
knows that we're passing out free health
care it will soon be many many more
how much will all of that cost this
country will pay for it how many more
doctors and nurses will we need to
provide that health care how many more
hospitals and clinics will we have to
build you'll Biden some would have to
build some how many well no one say no
one's saying anything precise about it
they haven't thought about the details
that's odd our health care system is
already overpriced and inadequate in
fact that's the main reason Democrats
won in
last election because they promised to
make it better now they're telling us
the solution the way they're going to
make it better is by giving unlimited
free medical care to foreigners who
break our laws
that's just lunacy there's no other way
to put it of course it's getting
virtually no coverage the media have no
interest in talking about something that
might embarrass their party but unlike
the Phantom threat of Russia this
actually matters a lot so we're gonna
look a little more deeply into it
tonight